i don't know if you listen to joe rogan
all those folks
they kind of um are doing something
interesting for mit
and and academia they're shaking up this
world a little bit
like podcasting because comedians are
paving the way for podcasting yeah
and so you have like andrew huberman
who's a neuroscientist a stanford friend
of mine now
yeah you know he he's like into
podcasting now and
you're into podcasting of course you're
not necessarily podcasting about
computer science currently right yeah
but that it
it feels like you could have a lot of
the free
spirit of the comedians implemented by
the people
who are academically trained who
actually have a
niche specialty yeah and then and then
that results i mean who knows what the
experiment looks like
yeah but that results me being able to
talk about robotics with joey diaz
yeah when he says you know drops f bombs
every other sentence and
i the world is like i've seen actually a
shift within
uh colleagues and friends within mit
where they're becoming much more
accepting of that kind of thing it's
very interesting that's interesting so
you're seeing exactly
okay because they're seeing how popular
it is they're like well you're really
popular yeah i don't know how they think
about it at georgetown for example
i don't know it's interesting but i
think what what happens
is the popularity of it combined with
just good conversations with people they
respect
it's like ah okay wait this is the thing
yeah and this is more fun to listen to
than a shitty zoom
lecture yeah about their work yeah it's
like there's something here there's
something interesting and we don't
nobody actually knows what that is just
like with like clubhouse or something
nobody's figured out like where is this
medium take is this a legitimate medium
of education
yeah or is this just like a fun well
that's your innovation i think was
we can bring on professors yeah and i
know joe rogan did some of that too but
but you know but your professor's in
your field
yeah you bring out all these mit guys
who i remember you know
well that's been the big challenge for
me is i don't
is i feel uh
i would i would ask big like
philosophical questions of
only people like yourself that are
like really well public like so for
example you have a lot of excellent
papers
on uh you know that a lot has a lot of
theory in it
right and there's some temptation to
just
go through papers and i think it's
possible to actually do that i haven't
done that much but i think it's possible
it just requires a lot of preparation
and i can probably only do that
with things that i'm actually like in
the field i'm aware of
but there's a dance that i would love to
be able to try to hit right where it's
actually getting to the core of some
interesting ideas as opposed to just
talking about philosophy
yeah at the same time there's a large
audience for people that just want to be
inspired by
like by disciplines where they don't
necessarily know the details
yeah but there's a lot of people that
are like hmm i'm really curious
i've been thinking about pivoting
careers into software engineering
they would love to hear from people like
you about computer science
even if it's like theory yeah but just
like the idea of that you can have big
ideas you push them through and it's
interesting
you fight for it yeah well there's some
uh there's what is that computer file
and uh uh number file these youtube
channels
there's uh there's channels i watch on
like chess exceptionally popular
where i don't i don't understand
maybe 80 of the time what the hell
they're talking about because they're
talking about like
why this move is better than this move
but i love the passion
and the genius of those people and just
overhearing it yeah
i don't know why that's so exciting did
you look at like scott erinson's blog at
all the yeah shuttle optimized yeah it's
like
hardcore complexity theory but it's
there's an enthusiasm
or like terry towel's blog a little bit
of humor yeah that jerry tower has a
blog
he used to yeah he would he uh and it
would just be
i'm going all in on you know here's the
new affine group with which you can be
whatever but i mean it's just
equations well in the case of scott
harrison he's good
he's able to turn on like the inner
troll and comedian and so on he's he
keeps the fun which is the best
and he's a philosophical guy he wrote
that turns out yeah
yeah so you know we're exploring these
different ways of communicating in
science and
and exciting the world
you